die wichtigsten
aktiver
groß groß
klein klein
das ist ein großer baum das ist ein
großer baum
dies ist ein kleiner baum dies ist ein
kleiner baum
gruß
klein
alt alt
jürgen jung
mein großvater ist alt er ist ein alter
mann
mein neffe ist 17 jahre alt er ist ein
junger mann
[Musik]
alt jung
alt alt
neu neu
er hat ein neues telefon das alte
telefon ist kaputt er hat ein neues
telefon das alte telefon ist kaputt
alt neu
[Musik]
dünn dünn
big dig
das ist ein
das buch es hat über 600 seiten
das ist ein dünnes buch es hat nur 30
seiten
das ist ein dickes buch das ist ein
dünnes buch
dünn dick
gut
schlecht schlecht
sie ist eine gute schülerin
er ist ein schlechter schüler
gut schlecht
früh früh
späth spät
ich gehe spät ins bett obwohl ich früh
aufstehen muss ich gehe spät ins bett
obwohl ich früh aufstehen muss
früh spät
richtig richtig
falsch
welches ist wohl der richtige weg
welche
ist wohl der richtige weg
da es war der
falsche weg
richtig falsch
schön schön
hässlich hässlich
das ist ein hässliches haus
hier möchte ich nicht wohnen
das ist aber ein schönes haus
hier hat es eine schöne aussicht
ja stimmt die aussicht hier ist sehr
schön
hier machen wir urlaub
[Musik]
schön hässlich
schwierig schwierig
einfach einfach
das ist aber eine schwierige aufgabe
das ist eine einfache aufgabe
schwierig einfach
schwer schwer
leicht leicht
wie schwer bist du
ich bin 26 kilo schwer
mann bist du leicht
er ist ein leichter junge
der elefant ist ein schweres tier
elefant ist ein schweres tier
[Musik]
schwer leicht
heiß heiß
kalt kalt
wenn das wetter heiß ist magisch kalte
getränke
[Musik]
wenn das wetter kalt ist liebe ich heiße
getränke
heiß kalt
teuer teuer
billig billig
dieser ring kostet 1 euro
das ist ein billiger ring
ich wünsche mir einen teuren ring
billig
sauber sauber
schmutzig schmutzig
er trägt
witziges unterhemden
er hat ein sauberes unterhemd angezogen
sauber schmutzig
lang lang
[Musik]
kurz kurz
im sommer trat
ich kurze hosen
im winter trage ich lange hosen
sie hat kurze haare er hat lange haare
lang kurz
stark stark
schwach schwach
er hat
er ist ein starker mann
[Musik]
juli aber
ist ein schwacher mann
brauche ich starken kaffee
ich habe aber nur schwachen kaffee zu
hause
darum muss es auf
kaffee trinken
stark schwach
schnell
lang
langsam
die schnecke ist ein langsames tier
usain bolt ist der schnellste mensch der
welt
keiner schneller als er
schnell langsam
[Musik]
www.hhl.de deutschen punkt ch
danke fürs schauen bitten leica das
video und abonniere unseren kanal
[Musik]